what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and before I get into it I just
want to give a shout out to Briggs from
all-day anime I got the idea for this
video from his tournament bracket about
badass hole dudes he did a while back
I'll link that video in the description
make sure show him some love and let's
get that man over 100,000 subscribers
ASAP he is so close if he hasn't hit it
already by the time this video was
published he also has many other
interesting tournament bracket videos on
his channel which you can check out this
series is going to be different though
rather than pitting the characters
against each other I'm just going to be
breaking down some of the most badass
old guys in anime and their badass feats
this video series like some of my other
videos about best geniuses on the best
revenge moments is not going to be in a
particular order so don't get upset if
your favorites aren't here just leave
them in the comments and they will
probably make an appearance in the
upcoming installments if we get 3000 yes
that's right 3,000 likes on this video
I'll start on the next one
ASAP if you have and be sure to
subscribe and ring that notification
bell or else you're definitely going to
miss the next one if you haven't be sure
to follow us on Twitter and Instagram
for more content and crucial updates
about new seasons for your favorite
anime keep in mind there will be anime
sporters and some manga spoilers in this
video in case that actually bothers you
the reason I decided to do this video is
because I am currently super obsessed
with the knowledge and wisdom these
elders have to pass on when well-written
badass old guys can be some of the most
compelling characters in anime they
often serve as role models for the anime
characters and for us as well and
currently I've been kind of obsessed
with you at each sheet from demon slayer
so I thought that this video would give
me a great opportunity to talk about him
so yes let's get into it
Yuri Chi is the breath of the Sun user
of legend in demon slayer he is
considered to be the strongest demon
slayer in history his fighting style the
breath of the Sun is considered to be
the strongest all other breath styles
are supposed to have originated from
this breath of the Sun style furthermore
your ichi is the only one we know of who
actually managed the corner moves on
until the latter managed to escape
somehow moves on the king of demons and
pop is the main antagonist of demon
slayer series from the beginning of the
series use presented SB
extremely powerful no one can really
touch him he survived for over a
thousand years some of his blood can
create demons strong enough to kill
pillars at this point in the manga he
easily overpowers every demon slayer
alive and this is why your each ease
past accomplishments are all the more
impressive
you each see as a human broke all the
rules he was more powerful than the
demon Godfather moves on and forced him
to run away from him he was supposed to
die at the age of 25 because he awakened
the demon slayer mark early but he
didn't he was supposed to get weaker
with age but he didn't when he was older
than 80 he ran into his older twin
brother who turned into a demon called
kakushi bow so that he can extend his
life and gain more power in contrast to
Kakashi Bo who has not aged your each he
has he now has an aged and decrepit body
obviously no matter how strong he used
to be no one would expect that this old
dude could beat his youthful looking
demon brother demon blood enhances ones
powers after all and allows him to stay
at their peak physical condition forever
in theory then you litchi surprises us
all including his brother by beginning
to cry and giving his sympathies to his
demon brother you're Ichi even though
he's old and on the brink of death
pities his youthful looking and
practically immortal demon brother then
he gets serious just as quick even
though he's supposed to be well past his
prime at this point his speed and power
is no weaker than it was when he was at
his prime he's just a strong his aura
alone makes Coco she bow the strongest
demon moon feel as if rocks have come to
rest on both shoulders yo Deecee ela
tells KOCO she bow when he's going to
attack so he can be completely prepared
yet you're Ichi is so fast that even
after the warning Kakashi bow doesn't
even have time to draw his sword before
his neck is cut kakushi bull knows that
you're ichi is going to finish him off
with his next blow but you're ichi dies
of old age before the final attack comes
he dies standing up to like another boss
we'll get into in a bit right up to his
final hour he was the strongest fighter
in the world even though he was past the
age of 80 kakushi bow had to admit that
your each's technique was nothing less
than godly even though Goku she will
survive he fell
like he'd been defeated because the gap
between their powers was so great like
Mouzon kakushi bow is still haunted by
oni she's immense power centuries after
his death but even more than his
overpowered Ness I love your Ricci's
personality even though he is so far the
strongest Demon Slayer in history and
arguably the strongest character - he
was always humble while the weaker
Kakashi bow talked big the stronger you
of each she always said he wasn't that
great even at a young age he considered
himself but a line in the long long book
of human history
he knew that children would be born who
surpassed him this didn't bother him
though he didn't need to be the best or
the strongest he smiled at the thought
that stronger demon Slayers would come
after he dies and as a result he could
rest easy he didn't need to save the
world right away or be the strongest
ever
he was happy just playing his part doing
the best that he could even as a kid
when Kakashi Bose said he wanted to be
the strongest samurai yo Deecee was fine
with being the second strongest your
ichi was a true stoic he didn't need the
universe to conform to his will to be
happy he was satisfied with doing his
best and living an honorable disciplined
and principled life he didn't fear death
or losing like hakushi bow and even when
he was at death's door he did not pity
himself but his brother whose fear of
death and defeat had turned him into a
monster yo Deecee will always serve as a
reminder to me that there are more
important things in life than simply
surviving at all costs that
paradoxically you can become more
successful if you let go of the
desperate need to be successful and
focus on the process instead and that
ultimately even the best of us are just
tiny blips in history and we shouldn't
take ourselves too seriously
we should smile and enjoy the present
moment because this breath might be our
last next let's talk about white beard
an anime character who always stood out
to me as being especially epic he was
known as the strongest man in the world
and the man closest to the one piece
back in the day white beard aka Newgate
was an orphan and his country was too
poor to be a member of the world
government so he became a pirate at an
early age and supported his village with
the money he got from piracy even from
the beginning it wasn't
treasure what white beard always wanted
was a family
and he got that in the form of the white
beard pirates his crew he viewed his men
as his sons he was also one of the few
men who could battle on equal terms with
Goldie Roger the pirate king himself he
earned the pirate Kings respect and
Roger even paid him a visit to say
goodbye before his death in time he was
given the title of yong-chol meaning he
was one of the four strongest and most
dangerous pirates in the world he was
always doing amazing selfless things he
went to Fishman Island and claimed the
island as his territory so that peace
would be restored to the island in this
way he kept others like pirates and
Marines from harming the Fishman and
merfolk that's just one of many islands
he protected in this way and if it seems
like he couldn't get any cooler he named
his ship the moby dick as a huge fan of
literature I can't help but think that's
awesome he went on to take in his former
rival son ace and even made him a
division commander when told that he was
his rival son he said it didn't matter
because all pirates are sons of the sea
he took him in and promoted him even
though ace tried to assassinate him many
times he eventually turned ace into the
most loyal of sons now that is a boss
then when ace got in trouble for trying
to defend white beards name white beard
showed up to try and save him even
though ace didn't follow orders when
white beard told him to let the insult
go during this moment Eight's tells his
crew to leave because he ignored their
warnings and brought this fate on
himself he didn't want to get them
involved in his execution however white
beard says no he sent him on that
mission and he gets Marco to back him up
he is more interested in saving his son
than anything else so he is willing to
rewrite history in a way that lets him
do exactly that for one of his sons
white peers willing to start the biggest
war and in the process he makes the
marine for dark one of my favorite arcs
in one piece if not my absolute favorite
the Fleet Admiral San Goku even says
that white beard has the power to
destroyed the world I don't know if
there's anything more badass that can be
said about someone than that someone
even mentions that watching the battle
at marine Ford is like watching the end
of the world keep in mind during this
battle white beard is
72 years old and still complete badass
white beard who ate the Gouda Gouda no
me fruit was extremely old Pete he could
create powerful shockwaves by shattering
the air like glass
this ability allowed him to create
earthquakes and tsunamis many more
things can be said about his powers and
skills but as with Yuri Chi it's his
character that impresses me more than
anything else although white beard
didn't fear death and he was ready to
die he didn't even end up getting beat
in a fair fight rather first he was
betrayed by one of his own allies and he
couldn't react quick enough because of
his deteriorating health and even then
after he gets stabbed by his own man he
doesn't try to kill him rather he hugs
him and tells him he still loves him
even though he was stupid enough to get
tricked into betraying him as with your
Ichi
white beard knew he could have remained
the strongest forever it was enough for
him to help his family and to help one
young pirate achieve his destiny in life
for him that's a complete life and he
accepts that some things like family are
worth dying for not only that he is so
inspiring that his whole giant crew is
willing to kiss their lives goodbye for
him when white beer begins to charge
sangoku says that the most dangerous man
in the world is charging at them quite
the compliment for a sick and injured 72
year old white beard even goes on to
help save our main protagonist Luffy who
unfortunately isn't strong enough at
this point to actually beat the stronger
Marines white beard and his crew do so
well that even the unwilling Marine GARP
grandpa of Luffy and an extremely badass
old dude in his own right has to get
involved in the fight along with the
fleet admiral sangoku the buddha and you
know that anyone was buddha powers is
insanely opie more on that later as the
battle progresses white beard search
spitting out blood and a chi nu tells
him that not even he can defeat old age
after taking a bunch of swords and
attacks white beard says you think you
can kill me like this he pretty much
screams that he's the white beard as he
cuts down everyone in front of him he
refuses to die until he's guided his
sons toward a brighter future it's not
at all surprising that people call him a
monster eventually Luffy and white beard
do
end up freeing ace they get his
handcuffs off and everything even though
his pirates are ready to sacrifice
themselves for him white beard says that
it is too cruel to make a father bury
his sons he says that everybody
eventually grows old and dies they did
what they came to do so he tells the
white beer pirates that it's time for
them to part his final order is for them
to survive and return to the new world
he's met his fate head on in the
manliest way possible he destroys marine
Ford the home of the strongest
organization in the world he sacrifices
his own life so as many of his sons as
possible can escape white beard
succeeded he opened up a window for ace
to escape however again
ace decides not to follow orders and
instead to defend white beards honor
when a kinda insults him ace even dubs
the name of this era white beard then he
sacrifices his recently saved life to
save Luffy from a kind whose punch then
white beard comes in and saves Luffy by
giving a kind was satisfying a much
deserved punch to his face like no one
else could do
he completely brings the Navy
headquarters building down in a canoe
curses him after losing half his face
from a kindness attack he still has
enough power to create a giant hold the
ground separating the Pirates from the
Navy giving them a chance to escape it's
not even the Navy that finally kills him
it's the Blackbeard pirates who all need
to team up to finish him off and even
then white beard has energy to say
something really important white beard
was never interested in the one-piece
treasure and that's why he didn't go get
it but he makes sure everyone knows that
it truly exists before he dies in this
way he encourages more people to become
pirates and encourages existing pirates
just as gol D Roger did before he died
all white beard was interested in was
getting a family and he got one and gave
his life in the end to protect it he
dies standing up never falling even in
death we are told he will forever be
remembered as a monster for the way he
destroyed his enemies that day in just
this battle he suffered 267 sword wounds
and was hit by 152 bullets and even 46
cannons that's right Ken
and yet his back and his white beard
tattoo received no wounds he didn't even
get one cowards wound which happens if
someone turns to run and get stabbed or
shot in the back while running as we're
told right until the end his pirate
pride stayed intact like your Ichi white
beard was still a beast right up to his
death and he also knew that there were
things worth dying for both accepted
their fate and that's bravely and
unselfishly white beard is definitely
what an old badass looks like at his
best and he will forever be remembered
as a legend next we have to talk about
Isaac net arrow from hunter hunter when
he was younger he was said to be the
most powerful men user in the world and
like the other guys in this video he
retains incredible power even in his old
age he was the 12th chairman of the
hunter Association and the head of the
exam Commission although usually dressed
in a kimono he fought in shorts and a
tight t-shirt that had the kanji for
heart written on it if you thought the
previous badasses were old NetID o is
over 110 years old what I liked about
metal is that despite his really old age
he still had a childlike energy and
playfulness he was the kind of guy who
got excited rather than scared at the
idea of fighting formidable opponents
when told that he would be completely
outmatched by Medwin the Chimera ant
king he replied that that was good news
he was thrilled at the idea of a good
challenge at his old age now enough
introductions let's jump to the fight
between metal and Medwin one of my
favorite fights in anime during this
fight metal shows off his Golden Buddha
related powers medow him gives him a
chance to escape alive but natural
insists on battling his insanely
powerful opponent even when Medwin
refuses to fight back metal provokes him
to attack by promising to tell the ant
king his true name what metal always
sought was the height of perfection his
dream was to give his heart and soul to
an unstoppable adversary and that's
exactly what he gets to do during this
fight even though he appears to be
completely outmatched
he still proclaims that their battle
location will be met whims grave even as
he's fighting the strongest being he
considers himself to be a lucky man who
is thankful for everything
they let him up to this point even past
the age of 110 he hasn't let the world
beat him down like so many people do
he hasn't become a pessimist rather he
continues to be positive and thankful
he's so thankful to have met him as an
opponent that he even forms a shape of a
heart with his hands and points it
towards the Chimera ant King even Medwin
cannot help but feel unresolved
admiration for this old badass when he
witnesses his power Medwin thinks that
that total must have yielded to an
emotion akin to insanity in order to
master this technique for an extremely
long time he devoted himself wholly to
that purpose as marrow and proclaims net
taro is a rare example of someone
transcending one's limits through sheer
effort no small compliment med om
commends the old man and that total
feels insulted because Medellin is
talking like he's so far above humans
although meadow him is impressed he
still has no fear for his life he is
still not hurt after all of Metro's
attacks
it just seems at this point like net
taro can only prolong the inevitable
eventually meadow and manages to take
net to his leg again meadow hem is
prepared to spare him he just tells him
to staunch the bleeding and to tell him
his name he again act smug and tells net
to know that he did good for a human
however natural is far from defeated his
drive does not diminish one bit and he
seals the wound in an instant but then
Medellin takes his arm but again net
todo is not fazed he just says that
he'll pray with one hand and uses the
attack zero hand net that concentrates
all his aura into this attack and Medwin
looks wounded after it but he's
ultimately fine he says the attack was
brilliant but it didn't even take a limb
from Edwin meadow and points out that
he's a king and net row is not of course
methanol could never win when Medwin is
sure he won nettle plays his final trump
card net total should look worried and
defeated but he's not at all and
Medellin feels fear for the first time
net row then stops his heart which sets
off a huge bomb inside his body he says
that the game was over before it even
started
meadow him with the help of his
assistants survives but only temporarily
he has been poisoned so net arrow did
manage to eventually kill this
unstoppable adversary by sacrificing
himself even though he was human Neto
actually ended up coming off as the
scarier of the two in his last moments
when he spoke of human malice
he was scarier than the Chimera ant king
could ever hope to be
we can go on and on about how amazing
and deep this fight is but the point is
that an old man over 100 years of age
managed to scare and eventually kill the
superhuman creature that had the power
to become the ruler of the entire world
and he did it in a tight t-shirt and
shorts the whole time med om was so sure
of his own superiority and the
inferiority of humans and yet a human
with the help of a human invention
defeated him natural was excited to
fight a seemingly unbeatable opponent
and he was ready to sacrifice his life
from the start not only did he accept
his fate he took pleasure in the final
battle even knowing that he was surely
going to die hunter hunter does a good
job of blurring the lines between good
and evil in this fight but what can't be
denied is that Metro comes off as one of
the most badass old dudes in all of
anime and that is it for today's video
remember if we hit 3,000 likes I will
drop some more badass sage wisdom in
part 2 so smash that like button like
metal smash med whens pride if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and ring
that notification bell so you actually
get notified when the new installment
drops for more content and crucial
updates about upcoming anime seasons
make sure to follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar a big thank
you goes out to our patrons over on
patreon who help make videos like this
one possible I especially want to thank
our pro hero tier patrons the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson Kings eldress angel Cruz Steelers
poet Pablo
atropos Wraith fitty dalla beat
accordion and Anatole
Cassatt Sookie and other one tier
patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans Stephen and Radha a Lola Mountain
Mattie Mac 239 makoto-kun and Sat Cooper
if you enjoy our work you can support
more by going over to patreon.com slash
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as $1 if you do so you'll
get your name featured in future videos
on
side these badasses right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord so check out patreon
anime outdoor link in the description if
you're interested you can also now join
the YouTube channel and support more
content that way if you prefer while
still getting the same great benefits
thanks again for everything I really
appreciate it
and until next time see you space
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]